taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
foods gonna fight but only one food can
be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
what's up taste buddies it's the taste
buds i'm joe i'm sal
good to see you all good to see you
buddy it's good to be back babe
yeah yeah we got pimp on the ones and
twos yeah
uh today's episode is soup versus salad
since
everybody seems to have a problem with
the reveal of the episode
can we address some things actually
let's address it okay so joe and i
batch recorded uh two or three times for
the first like handful of episodes
and they hadn't been released yet and we
thought that they would be released
in order but then we realized that we
had some that we liked we thought we
we would prefer to choose the order yeah
and so unfortunately in some of the
earlier episodes
we reference episodes that hadn't come
out yet right we know that was an error
we see your comments we hear you we love
you we respect you
and so we want to let you know that we
are making note of that and that won't
happen going forward right and i want to
apologize that we didn't run them in the
order we recorded
uh we ran them out of order uh and and
again i i apologize that we tried to
give you guys the best possible
absolutely free show we can throw us
right up on a cross
what we did was please get the nails and
the hammer
what we did was we tried to give you the
best possible slotting of order for your
maximum enjoyment
we are sorry that some of you heard
which juice
was better and had a full-blown
conniption um no we get it it's annoying
and i was
and we we also were like ah yeah but we
were upset when the spoilers went out
too
but i honestly i would have uh caught
some of that
i am so disgusted by the sight of myself
and the sound of my own voice i won't
listen to these
i'll never hear this again once it's out
of my mouth that's it you gotta
understand pimp comes in he goes i got
all this 4k equipment
like 4k that's the latest and greatest
sign us up and then
we watch ourselves and we're just
disgusted with ourselves
you know i had i had a i had a seed in
my tooth
on one of these episodes yeah it was
like 50 minutes in my tooth
no nobody said anything okay he does not
lie
it doesn't matter no one said anything
to me and everyone's like you got
something in your teeth
the 4k man it's just you know what i'm
saying so
yeah it's rough it's rough stuff baby
i'll tell you it's rough stuff
uh what else what else what else how
have you been some of you i mean
one more thing though some of you guys
are like eat the food
eat the food here's the thing about that
guys we thought about it
um we've had these foods hundreds of
times we're not gonna bite into the food
and have any realizations or revelations
but
the thing is you don't want us to eat
the food you think you know better but i
don't think you want to just hear us
chewing
on a mic food that we've already had i
think it it adds some dead air
you're going to watch me digesting food
and chewing it and swallowing it
it's not necessary that said that said
when we do live shows and we are going
to do some
also live youtube stream shows
uh in the very near future on those we
might incorporate
pulling out the stops for those yeah
some of the taste testing because those
are more special events things yeah
but every time we record you don't want
to hear us eating yeah
uh plus then we have to go get the foods
and
we're very busy we're very busy i uh
i'm uh i'm sitting these days in my
apartment like
like jim carrey in the grinch just
just staring into an abyss i don't even
have a dog with antlers to keep me
company
jesus christ i know i mean i'm not doing
the same but here's the thing too
uh oh and one more thing people because
we want to address all this because it's
been a few weeks since we've done our
last batch of episodes
and you know we we stay active with your
comments um
people are like put up a poll when
you're done
here's the thing guys the show is not
live right right so i don't know how
you're all watching at different speeds
so what we might do is
since mondays are for the buds and at 11
am monday the
the show drops we're thinking maybe we
can do we're looking into it
at eight o'clock on a monday and when
after you've all had about nine hours to
digest it and watch it
we'll throw up a poll and you can we can
do that poll
maybe based on the argument now i don't
know who that's going to be
yeah i don't know paul that says who won
the you saw the episode who won the
argument
as if for everybody criticizing me in
the comments
as if my self-esteem isn't low enough
this is what i'm willing to do for this
show i'm gonna
allow a poll to go online
[Laughter]
no no so what we both have fans and
listen to me
no we blow their face but you uh my
board game is not on the shelf at the
target i shot it
i understand that i understand that but
for the people that have followed me
here because you knew me before
whatever have you be honest i don't you
know you don't want to
be but they're going to be honest
they're going to judge the food
and they're going to judge the arguments
that's absurd to think that
they would they would just vote for me
just for me vote on who wins the
argument
one guy every week that goes derozan
switched me with his argument once again
it's one guy
um i i love i think half the time we
make a great argument
i uh i listen part of me is is that is
the how funny it is that
the the fan the legions uh just
clobbering me but also
taylor you make fantastic arguments i
kind of broke down what this show is
uh like argumentatively what the show is
yeah
and it's passion versus hubris that's
really what it is
all right you're a passionate guy you
collect data and you
yeah and i'm just like go shove it up
your ass
right right it's it's brash versus you
know
uh whatever the brains
but i don't know you have plenty brains
and you got plenty of brush
and we're just like you know great team
anyway uh yeah so so we might start
putting this
can i just tell you though sometimes you
make these metaphors that don't do you
favors i'm trying to talk to you about
this
you'll be like that's like and then you
say something that it's
not like like very much not like
your toes are too close to me i'm very
comfortable
i wanna i don't like this i get [ __ ] for
everything i put a pillow on my listen
by the way the [ __ ] the pillows guys
we're in my home we're on the couch the
pillars are here
so if we're not holding the pillows the
pillows are stacked in the middle i'd
like to have the pillow here to put my
elbows on
as almost like a thing but i got to
justify now that i don't have a
with a you know there's a pillow on my
lap because i don't even know
if we were not recording right now how
would i be sitting
there is no way you would sit like this
with me just to talk and hang out
there's no way not only this is insane
not only are you
wild for saying that but i am actually
beside myself
because i thought that you know me well
not to be like he would be like this
exactly if we weren't even recording
there's no way and in fact if we weren't
recording i wouldn't have had the guts
to say to you
sal i'm uncomfortable by this oh that's
probably where the disconnect is
you're uncomfortable your toes are a
little close to me and you've got yellow
tip socks on it's
you know yeah but so what
all right leave it i mean i'm not gonna
i can do the show these are fresh socks
just put them on
it's not just out of the shower really
like i i i don't think you're dirty in
any
there's something a little too sensual
about your toes being near me oh but you
don't live a sensual lifestyle
i do but not to be shared with you quite
frankly
you know i'm just trying to get
comfortable and since now by the way not
allowed to have a pillow near me
and i'm just stretching my [ __ ] out and
now i have nowhere to go on the couch
i'm forced in this position you're not
going anywhere you really stand
where you are fair enough go i could
pull this back but eventually my foot's
going to fall asleep
no no no stretch it out i want you to be
comfortable because you're going to get
clobbered in this debate today you're
going to get clobbered
just stretch out take a breath relax
come on go ahead you know what's going
to you know when you won't like it when
i'm laying on my stomach like this
today's debate as i already stated
soup versus salad yeah sal you are team
soup i am team salad
i already see it on this jesus christ
are you kidding me soup was apparently
the apparently a dinosaur invented soup
it's soup it's been around since 20
000 before christ that's christ is an
all-knowing there is a ubiquitous entity
to document that
there is no way of documenting that it
is funny that's outrageous yeah no that
is funny how do you document
soup from 20 000 bc when was salad
invented before we start here
what's a salad 1860s in russia
that's a way worse story oh good
tell us defend the 1860 russian
dish it just it oozes appeal
20 000 bc i think soup was i think soup
was the first food
that wasn't just like let me just bite
this rat
they didn't have rats back then all
right i didn't in the 20 000 bc when did
we get rats
oh rats came after uh what do you what
do you what do you know
no rats were um you know it was an
evolution of uh
rabbits you
joe this is what i'm saying to you you
here's what you need to stop doing you
need to pump the brakes
on throwing out wild wild accusations
i was kidding oh it was a joke well then
you delivered it
with a term a firmness that we're
worried about better call saul
rats the uh evolution this is ridiculous
54 million years ago rats were invented
get the get out invented this is absurd
who invented the look at this the norway
rat norway didn't exist 54 million years
ago
that's crazy everything's suspected they
call it norway rap but maybe it was post
name that
66 million years it says the rat has
been around
yeah that's outrageous i mean that's so
so far
before soup and we've never eaten rat
nobody's eating rat
hmm i don't know that's kind of why
we're in this position not a lot of
people have eaten rat
all right let's get the
what's the moment who is the human being
and what's the moment that someone went
like this
about 66 million years ago we had rats
like what were they
what was the data they were comparing
that they mined this is what i'm saying
they made it up
i don't even know how you could tell me
soups from twenty thousand years ago you
can't it's insane yeah twenty thousand
telling me christ
twenty thousand try twenty
you would think christ made it it's also
insane by the way
that a legitimate uh like historical
uh uh uh
what is it called like like a legitimate
historical marker is still
bc that's crazy
yeah that's crazy how were rats around
it should be b z before zero oh oh okay
because that means christ was born in
zero right yeah
i guess when he was born everyone was
like start counting okay
yeah yeah all right well in any case
what year was he born
in zero that's what bc is
yeah but like in the bible they were
like you know that christmas
that christmas it was december 25th
january 1st that year was zero four
beasts
using these methods most scholars assume
a date of birth between
six and four bc and that jesus preaching
began around
27 to 29 a.d so he started preaching
close to his death uh yeah
he died young he was like cocaine but if
he said he starts preaching
he started preaching in in 27 to 29 a.d
but he was born foreign
he could have been born as early as 6 bc
jesus could have been 42.
they've really been throwing that 33
around liberally
they had it for years how was jesus born
how was christ born before christ nobody
knows this is what i'm saying
why are we making jesus the marker and
not just the year zero the marker
nothing against jesus
i'm just saying make zero the mark yeah
also how was
did we have months before years because
he was born on christmas
but it wasn't it was christmas is five
days before zero
right yeah but no they've so why didn't
they
why wasn't december 21st in essence
january first day
25th now 2024 they've proven
i think i think they've proven this that
that he was not born on the 25th that
that's like uh
that's kind of not real
45 bc wait julius caesar is that close
to jesus
i thought caesar was way after that god
all right let's
see well i thought it was the
greco-roman is that the greco-roman
the roman gr was it the roman calendar
the greco-roma isn't it
i don't know the grecian i didn't even
know when rats came into the calendar
consisting of 12 months based on the
solar
in line all right launch the pole let's
jesus it's all brought us to this moment
yeah let's start the debate
soup versus salad here we go baby soup
versus salad choose one
sweet's out out out
i give you the floor first you tell me
on what planet
you think soup beats out salad well and
wild earth
you know okay let's start with that all
right go ahead i'm listening to this
search done just a moment
ago shows us that soup has been around
for 22
000 okay and the salad has been around
about 150.
so soup is amazing because you know how
you know how evolution and technology
are never a good thing but yeah but yeah
but go ahead soup right
soup is a lot of things to a lot of
people soup is a comfort food
soup is a healing food soup is a hearty
food
soup is good food soup is good food soup
crosses all
boundaries all planes super all
all nationalities ethnicities all across
the world
uh soup is a ubiquitous dish that people
have their own version of so it's it's
it's real it's adaptable
soup is it it has so much sustenance in
it
it could be healthy it could be
indulgent
right it can help you with a chest cold
it can give you vitamins it
it can be a meal and of itself it could
be a starter for a meal
when people say oh how do we have soup
and salad
soup's always ahead they never go let's
have some salad and soup well because
the opener goes before the headliner
the soup and salad i think salad is a
headliner no
i think salad is that little in between
almost like a palate cleanser get your
roughage in there for digestion
okay bottom line if i had to choose a
food for the rest of my life that's cold
or hot
i'm gonna want a hot food as well a lot
of times salads skew
cold and if i want a meal like i'm not
gonna have a salad for breakfast lunch
and dinner
but i can make a big bowl of soup and
like the for a few days after that
i could just hit that soup for any of
those meals i really do believe that
i could have soup before my main meal as
my main meal
after my main meal uh i feel like after
your main meal
you would desert a soup not that i would
desert it but
if you want to bring in stuff like
gazpacho and things like that you do
have a cold version of soup
sure second plate as an appetizer just
like and perform the function of a salad
right i like that soup has no boundaries
right you can almost look at what's in
your fridge and concoct the soup
there's no rules to soup also you take
classic soups because there are many we
can name them you can name a minestrone
you can name a chicken noodle you can
name a french onion you can name a split
pea you can name an italian wedding
right
every one of those if i say oh i want to
taste your chicken noodle his chicken
noodle
her chicken noodle and their chicken
noodle it could all be different
so even within the confines of you know
the recipe for that soup there's
variations within it
i just think soup is like a super power
food
and i i i just let me see americans eat
more than 10
billion bowls of soup each year
10 billion joe and the most popular
soup variety is chicken noodle and and
just as a sidebar
why don't you tell the folks how you
feel about your chicken noodle soup is
the worst soup that's ever
existed it's the most boring soup that's
ever existed
it is there's nothing worse in the
noodle department than a plain noodle
noodles are the best when they're
dressed up with
a wonderful lo mein uh uh
you know uh uh uh recipe uh pastas
with with cheeses and and vegetables and
beefs
and and sauces added to them this is
when your noodle shines
chicken is best dressed up barbecued
chicken
fried chicken even a roasted chicken
you know what nobody cares about pulled
white breast meat
unseasoned chicken so you take chicken
noodle soup
i'm not saying but that should be
seasoned and it's chicken broth
the worst of all broths with
plain flavorless chicken dropped into it
plain noodles dropped into it and then
if you're lucky
chunks of carrot and celery which is
nothing a
person has ever wanted to eat ever on
their own
oh no you never seen somebody if you see
somebody on their own
if you see somebody eating celery
straight up that is a
psycho run for the hills everybody agree
people put peanut butter on celery the
carrot sticks they dip it in ranch
dressing whatever
you drop those into chicken broth they
taste like celery and carrots and flax
in fact that chicken broth sucks the
little flavor they already had
out of them okay it is a lousy boring
soup that only people enjoy when they
are so
deathly ill that anything outside of
that
or planned toast will make them vomit
horrendously everywhere
this is though how boring and terrible
chicken noodles it would be completely
on your side with everything you said
except it's all completely wrong
it's 100 right no it's not it's not
you're talking about a bland soup
i'm talking about the best iteration of
these soups
no every chicken noodle is planned name
any tissue
dish every chicken noodle if it was a
bad dish no no no no no no chicken
noodle by nature is a bland soup
every chicken noodle soup is bland when
you get one that has
kick okay okay when you get one that's
got a lot of spices and stuff in it
that's a special occasion and you know
it that's not
and you know it joe there's a reason
chicken noodle soup when somebody gives
you an italian most
popular soup of all time it's not
because it sucks it's because people are
dumb
that's right i disagree that people are
dying and people are sickly too
so they eat something when they're sick
that's right let me go i get a
man i got a wicked ass chest cold my
head is killing me
i don't have any strength i just want to
get up under the covers and i just want
to have a garden salad let me ask you
nobody says that
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question
can you can you make me a garden cellar
no one says that let me ask you a
question
let me ask you a question this thing's
medicine let me ask you a question
ready you got two people
okay uh one is a guy that entertains you
right lights up your life whatever right
the other is a guy that whenever you're
sick
comes over makes you feel better you say
who's the best guy you're gonna go
oh they're probably the guy that makes
me feel better because he makes you feel
better
he helps you when you're sick you're
talking okay let's not talk about
chickens
just chicken noodle now no i'm talking
about chicken noodle but
right now i know but i'm just chicken
noodles i understand but i'm just
hammering all my you this is a series of
books that have billions of copies sold
called
chicken soup for the sauce the worst
books ever written nobody's saying
the worst ever written nobody's saying
black and tilapia salad for the soul
let me tell you what are you talking
about i'll get back to the broader
argument let me know
when someone says when someone's making
fresh soup what fills the house
aromas of herbs and spices and home
comfort yeah
oh man there's a pot boiling down there
when you when you're making a salad
let me tell you why your argument fails
something is someone making a delicious
sense let me tell you
let me tell you why your argument fails
i'll sum it up in one
sentence one sentence that's all i need
buddy
nobody has ever walked into a restaurant
and said i'll just have the soup bar
it's never been said you can't ever
ever always said nobody has ever said
that nobody's ever said this
because it doesn't exist how many times
did somebody go in the restaurant and go
i'll just have a salad bar
you go into a ponderosa you go into a
sizzler i disagree
you go into a soup plantation and
there's a
salad bar and then they also had to add
a potato bar
because soup can't carry the name of the
restaurant
your defense right now is that salad
bars exist the salad could go eat
are you nuts there is nothing holding
people
when you go to a new york deli right now
there's a salad salad
at the end of that there's five pots of
soup that means
usually two and guess what it's worth it
they're usually full
because nobody gives a [ __ ] that's nice
nobody gives a [ __ ]
oh let me open the thing that's not
covered by glass that people are
sneezing and drooling into all day
and by the way that is sit there in its
own steam for so long
it just looks like greenish liquid at
this point nobody even knows what it is
by the way by the way by the way salad
is like a scam as well it's like
oh we got tomatoes we got onions we got
some croutons we got some leaves
you mean nurturing life-giving
vegetables tomatoes we got croutons we
got
how's it different well the chickens
how dare you oh yeah you guys thank you
pecan you've got shrimp on top
you've got salmon on top you've got
chicken on top you've got steak on to go
into a
sally babe hey this is it
oh we got this is how how nice this is
joey roses
aka joe derosa's sandwich shop has
brought a platter of sandwiches
a platter of sandwiches for us to eat
and taste it now
because of the nature of quarantine i
have not been down to the shop this is
gonna be my first
bite this is it this is your first one
and i've plugged the sandwich pop up
many times we're at the stand in
nyc in union square uh every week
always follow the instagram at joey
rose's hard eight
i'm glad that dory covert two you bit it
and then put it right down on top of
a plate of clean sandwiches
jesus christ we're at the stand in union
square every week
where's the spread from we make it what
we make it we make it in our hotel we
make it in-house
quality stuff eight sandwiches for eight
bucks a piece you can't beat it these
are cheaper than going to subway and
it's ten times the quality
so i mean come on down enjoy us
i'm not kidding around this is dull
absolutely delicious like
home run quality ingredients they fill
you better
they taste better they are better joey
roses we do quality
better that's right sandwiches elevated
a brand based around phallus talk
put it in your mouth you know as part of
my uh saturday morning routine i used to
wake up i used to eat
dancing nearly well dancing is part of
it i used to get up i used to dance i
used to leave it all out on the living
room floor
and i used to finish one box of cereal
with skim milk really and watch my
cartoons my programs
i love eating cereal and then as you get
older i don't think cereal is a thing
for adults because it's just going to
kill you very fast
it goes away it's a shame it sucks it's
just loaded with sugar that's the point
so
magic spoon who is a new sponsor of our
show is a cereal that comes in the
flavors of cocoa
frosted fruit blueberry all stuff like
that but here's the thing it's zero
sugar it's 11 grams of protein a serving
and
only three net carbs it's a keto
friendly cereal and it tastes amazing
that's the difference
it tastes like you're actually having
real cereal because you are i don't know
how they did it
but cereal you could start eating it by
the bowl again while you watch cartoons
i know i don't i don't understand how
they did it either it's gluten free it's
grain free it's soy free
it's gmo free but it's not free and this
is where we come in
okay you got to go to magicspoon.com
taste buds that's how you get there then
once you put in slash taste buds at
checkout
you also enter a promo code of taste
buds and you're getting five bucks off
uh your order your first variety pack
variety pack of four so you try all four
flavors yeah and out of the four i gotta
say i
thought they were all delicious but i
really really liked blueberry quite
a bit and it was followed close second
by the fruit flavor
yeah fruit flavor to me this was amazing
you know you worry oh is it going to
taste like diet fruit loops
you know going like no
it just tasted like slightly healthier
fruit
right i was fine with that yeah like i
was really fine with that it was
delicious so
listen it's backed this this deal is
back to 100
with a happiness guarantee so if you
don't like this stuff for any reason
they're going to refund your money
no questions asked go over to
magicspoon.com
tastebuds and then use the promo code
tastebuds save five bucks on that
variety pack try it today this is a
right up our alley as well
if you know the show you know what we're
about as a matter of fact we have a
serial episode coming up very very soon
very soon so magic spoon came at just
the right time
uh we appreciate it magic spoon try it
out got
you've got you got people throw fruit
into salad
people throw all types of vegetables all
kinds of root vegetables in the salad
people throw cooked baked potato into
salad there's
the variety of cheeses you can put into
salad and you know what
this is another thing that never happens
nobody ever walks to a salad bar and
goes i'm sorry what is this
when you go to a soup canister in a deli
and you open it
there better be a little card there to
tell you what it is
otherwise you have no goddamn idea how
is that
argument applicable to which is better
because you can't sorry i want to
identify food
you can't identify supervisors i think i
think i think i should know what it is
got some spinach got some beans i'll
taste it so it's cream based and i know
what it is oh yeah yeah but guess what
the car's usually there anyway i'm not
arguing whether you can identify soup on
site
like i'm just telling you something
nobody's ever like god
damn it the salad no you're wrong there
are entire
entire multiple chain restaurants
devoted to
salad okay there are almost none devoted
to soup
and the few that are devoted to soup
have to have salad bars
you go back to you go let's let's let's
look at this right let's take it let's
take it out of the salad bar let's think
about
family recipes passed down and oh my god
you have you have a you have a uh a
french on your friendship you're
affection you're all decent this one's
not good
but there's something in his friendship
oh it's a family recipe i'll never i'll
never let it go
soup recipes are recipes that are
guarded and passed down for generations
they're in a book in an old nana's
kitchen nobody's ever like
you give me a recipe to this salad bro
what's in this
what's in the salad oh it's it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's a spring
mix
okay spring mixture i'm eating twigs
from a field so you're saying spring mix
so you're unidentified [ __ ] in the
spring so you're saying
you're saying hold on a second so you're
saying you need clothes
people so if you haven't let me finish
it let me finish let me finish
let me be honest i've needed to be
finished get through salads
because of salad you need crackers to
get through soup
[Music]
you that you sip that hot drink down
and think that that's a satisfying meal
even french onion soup which is my
favorite soup of all time
which i would cross a walk 500 miles to
get a good bowl of i love french onion
soup
even that does not work yeah well you
know
even that doesn't satisfy me as a meal
soup is not a meal it's a hot
drink that's a meal shower could be a
meal that is leaves now it could be a
you can have cheese meat vegetables and
dressing on salad that's a full meal
please dressing dressing ninety-nine
percent of people
salad many salads with prepared dressing
have more calories than double
cheeseburger okay
so it's true
that doesn't mean a salad is lying to
you that doesn't mean it's not a meal
that means it's a meal right there
you're getting calories well people
immediately need to go i need croutons
and i
put my dressing on the side hold the
onions nothing
there is nothing more satisfying
than a killer salad bar nothing next to
a deli tray
next to an amazing deli tray i disagree
i think that a
a hearty delicious bowl of soup is more
satisfying
than a cold bland salad so when you let
me ask you a question you don't need to
mess with your question
right away by the way good luck let me
ask you questions
hashtag wilted yeah because that's how
quality food works
okay you know what you can leave a
snickers bar in your countertop for
three years it's still going to taste
fresh
that's what you're supposed to do it's
just snickers soup cold
how about that the next day i'll have it
different flavors on the bottom hot meat
on the top what do you think of that
that's disgusting it's not disgusting
yeah you got
hot meat with cold lettuce a lot of
people do it a lot of people do it
here's here's what here's what i'm
saying here's what i'm saying
hold on when's the last time you've gone
to a traditional like an old school
stadium
you asked me a question i go like
yesterday no no no okay
it's not yesterday when's the lesson he
went to an old school steakhouse
and got excited because you could walk
up to the soup bar
it's never happened thanks for just
making me think about covent
it's never happened you walk up to the
salad bar
it's an event bub a soup bar is not a
thing though
because soup stinks you can't compare a
salad bar
to not a soup bar sure i can but they
put
soup on the end of the salad bar they
put two canisters
okay okay ready
you can't you to pick one for the rest
by the way you know what else
you have this conversation versi chose
salad too
and i didn't get it you know what else
you don't get on the menu
it'll say salad let's just say the
chicken caesar just for argument's sake
or maybe the cobb another home run salad
okay
cobb's a great salad but hold on it'll
say
it'll say on the menu would you like the
entree portion
or the small one it is never once set on
a menu with soup
would you like the entree portion it is
not because it's always
an entree no it's spot but you never
heard a cup of bowl
you tell a bowl is it an entree it
wouldn't fill you up and you know it
wouldn't and you goddamn no it would
depend
the size of the bowl the size of the
bowl
you know the size of the bowl they're
putting down in every restaurant and you
know goddamn well it's not filling you
up
you know it's not i i cannot argue
something that is that irrational you
have
never once gotten an entree-sized soup
at a restaurant
you've had to order multiple bowls in
minutes
you had to get a refill you started this
argument by going notice with salads
they say regular
entree portion they don't do that with
soup i'm like cup of bowl you're like
that's not the same
mole is not a bonus i have never dude on
seinfeld
seinfeld soup's not a meal soup's not a
meal jerry
yes it is bonya this is the meal they
argue about the soup not being
substantial enough okay
no it wasn't the salad nazi right only
one place
what does the word entree mean a meal
soup is of course soup is not him the
salad's not a meal either it's not a
meal
not a meal bub listen to me it's why
it's so blithely tossed on as a super
salad addendum
all right oh that doesn't help you that
doesn't no don't gloss past that but the
salad can be a filling meal
on its own if you include the right
ingredients
i'm sorry he googles his super meal and
his salad meal
and the first two things that come back
cement the argument that salad is a meal
i argue that soup is more of a meal than
salad despite what the internet is
telling me
now the internet facts aren't any good
you want to bring up seinfeld
people lined up for blocks and still do
for soup nazi soup there's no salad nazi
no one's going
no salad for you what time of day what
time of day they line up all the times
today no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no what time of day do
they line up during the day
why light lunch light lunch
i'm working i'm going from break i've
got people what are you arguing there's
some arguing
i'm arguing that soup is better than
salad you're arguing portion size now
no i'm telling you that salad is better
because it is a more substantial and
more
varied thing bro i can give you a a bowl
of soup that weighs three pounds
goddamn soup and i could give you a
salad that fills a dixie cup what does
that mean
we're talking my point you keep arguing
that salad's more of an honor no
restaurant shall
sell serves an entree form of soup the
flavor profiles of salads on the whole
the mixing and the stewing and the
marinating of different vegetables and
meats and herbs and spices
come together for a bite that ultimately
is way better
than spearing chicken spearing lettuce
and then dipping it into the batter
popping it in your mouth nothing better
than spirits eating soup is better but
it's not a bite up with her
because i'm putting it into my soup now
you like fun now you like it i did not
like it my point is i don't have to do
it to get through the bowl
sometimes i gotta i i don't need
croutons to get through
i need crouton help i need help from
croutons to get me through i don't know
i don't i can't remember the last time i
had a crouton
i don't eat croutons to get through
salad ever as a rule
soup is the better choice people ask
which is better super salad as a rule
soup is the better choice soup has a
high water content which can help you
feel full
and just like a salad it's a good
vehicle for vegetables and fiber and
vegetables promotes feelings of fullness
and
calories let me tell you about the
vegetables in soup you're getting
nothing out of them everything has been
steamed or
roasted or boiled out of that revolution
who's there iceberg lettuce it is no
nutritional value i don't eat iceberg
lettuce i go i go romaine
i go butter okay brooklyn butter okay
i go green leaf i go red leaves i mean
god bless you and your leaves
i go a rich i go a rich green okay there
is no nutritional value left in
anything in soup it has been steamed and
cooked out of it already
all of it it's like eating stir
stir-fried vegetables i agree with that
that's a hundred percent true you're
telling me every bowl of soup is just
void of nutrition
when you cook vegetables like that they
lose everything
yeah but i'm not also okay some loss of
vitamins is unavoidable in any food
preparation particularly
in cooking soups made with vegetables
can still be a good source of vitamins
and other nutrients
provided they are properly prepared
considerable vitamin loss occurs in
wilted and dehydrated
vegetables wilted that rings a bell
uh yeah salad doesn't even keep dude you
you if you dress that sound you throw it
in the fridge the next day you're not
eating that salad
every the lettuce has gone because the
lettuce has gone off and
only an idiot dresses uh too much salad
in one sitting you dress the porsche
i'm saying a soup the next day could be
just as good
leftover soup great great i mean my
point again but i'm arguing the merits
of
taste and what i like better you're
arguing the merits but i but i just
increased it
if you don't dress the salad and you put
it in the fridge properly it's plenty
great the next day
you have to store it properly most
salads are just boring dude oh come on
yeah yeah yeah go ahead blue cheese
italian creamy italian
cigarette yep ranch mmm
okay your name and dressings these are
just these are just
five let's name soup bases
tomato chicken beef
and we're spent aren't we you're right
you're done
you're right there's no seafood there's
no there's no there's no other soups to
use there's not a vegetable base
there's not vegetable based tomatoes
chicken and chicken or chicken or tomato
base
i bring up top 10 soups versus top 10
salads i go down a row with you i go one
on one
and i guarantee you eight out of ten
super cookies are endless with salad
there's no way to name the possibilities
are endless with soup
that's what was my early appointment
everything in the broth
go ahead i'm listening give me a chat i
named something no no don't look at the
screen
give me 10 what does that matter give me
10 off you go ahead give me 10.
okay cream of mushroom cream of tomato
okay hold on slow down
cream of mushroom sucks all right no no
it does not it's
one of my favorite soups creamy tomato
good soup new england
manhattan okay mmm don't forget those
bread bowls
don't forget those bread boys i hate
bread balls but go ahead sure you do
sure you do put salad in a bread bowl if
you wanted to put salad in a bread bowl
if you wanted to
great i'm not impressed chicken noodle
chicken and rice
yeah which you you don't think is that
great you told me downstairs
no but i'm just naming you powerhouse
super people i'm saying name me ten
bangers that you think are bangers come
on okay i couldn't even make myself
french onion soup
chicken noodle soup i don't know if you
think chicken and rice is enough of a
variation if it's not no problem
hot and sour soup i love it uh
uh well it depends where you want to go
now that just opened up a whole
uh you know asian inspired window for me
but
i got you know what i love wonton soup
you know why because it's got big
mealy ball soup pumpkin
delicious soup delicious come on yeah
italian wedding
that's what you make because you got
stuck with pumpkins
split please lentil i mean i mean these
are just
these things are all powerhouses in
their own right what do you want me to
do here chicken caesar
cobb yeah steak and blue cheese salad
okay
okay yeah yeah yes you're pumping the
breaks
asian salad it's a three asian salad
seaweed sauce give it to you
seaweed salad i love seaweed sauce
shouldn't have put it there
you don't have a bowl of seaweed salad
you said hot and sour soup
yeah like chinese soup like hot and sour
i it's got tomatoes
i got my tomatoes it's got mushrooms i
think seaweed salad is just as good as
hot sour soup
seaweed salad is seaweed salad is a it's
a
you eat a fist full of it it's like it's
like you get it like as a throwaway
mandarin salad
no mandarin is more like the oriental
salad with the noodles in it
you're flat floundering at times i'm not
floundering i'm not floundering
chef salad boom
that wasn't a mic job you just can't mic
drop stuff that's not a mic
shut sucks by the way are you nuts a
chef's salad is like i wish i could have
a sandwich but i don't have any bread
oh are you crazy ham and cheese and a
salad your bowl
any pasta salad any pasta salad what
you're talking about the loose
little loose i'm talking about when they
combine like the salami and the cheese
and everything in the dressing salad
you're eating cubes potato salad
you're throwing but gladly throw pasta
salad
throw potatoes pasta salad mixed potato
salad yeah these these are get these
hate us out as an abomination that's
right
are you insane let me tell you something
are you insane
90 of the time they suck i'm not saying
there's not good versions of them
the deli the traditional deli potato and
pasta
is just this tangy mayo with these
undercooked potato chunks in it it's
just potato salad is the greatest
salad potato salad is the greatest
sandwich side dish of all time
of all time oh my god this guy of all
time we're going to stay at dessert
fruit challenge i mean just because
something has the word salad in it he's
making he's doing it again
it's a salad so a bowl of fruit you're
going to call a fruit salad that's what
it's called it's up against my
soup that's what it's called never heard
of a fruit soup
you got a fruit soup it's got to have a
fruit soup
do you have a fruit soup is this this
this this
this this is fruits with soup there's
super fruits what is it
gazpacho's maybe have something no no no
no no she's got no fruit in it no
holiday fruit soup okay oh yeah yeah you
know that old
classic fruit soup yeah that old classic
holiday fruit soup
oh i remember as a boy having that every
christmas [ __ ] about the fruits bro
i don't give a [ __ ] about them you're
the one throwing in macaroni and fruit
to help you they're huge
spring mixes they're huge salads ah you
know what
you're full of crap all right let's go
to the polls we're at 40 minutes about
here let's go to the polls kiddo
wait wait pimp don't reveal it yet all
right hold on a second i
i gotta be honest here i i just i really
think soup's gonna win
i i i just if you have to choose i'm one
versus the other
if you had to okay if i told you that
you had to
in this hypothetical only one thing for
the rest of your life
wouldn't you choose soup over salad not
in a million
years a salad i love something three
meals a day every day
versus a cold or hot soup a hearty
sausage i'll tell you what i'm gonna do
you tell me i can have one food for the
rest of my life
i'm cutting it down to two meals first
of all breakfast is out the door
okay yeah they say some say that's the
most important meal and then i'm having
salad
a hearty salad at lunch and at dinner
that's what i'm doing man i i feel like
sometimes i don't know you
why because that's that's salad is so
refreshing it's so nutritious so good
for you it's so wonderful
so crisp it's such an array of flavors
it's such a kaleidoscope
and it's a meal on a plate you could
separate the ingredients of a salad
and have a full course meal you can't do
that with soup
that's wrong it's not wrong what do you
mean joe just like to say
if i gave you a steak the chicken pasta
the carrots yeah
and now i got a plate of i'm having
grilled chicken with pasta pasta and
carrots in the symbol i just did
the simplest version of it the simplest
version of it if i gave you a plate with
a beautiful seared steak on it okay
and next to it a wonderful caesar salad
you would say i had a great steak dinner
tonight
there's a salad that exists where that
steak is sliced up and incorporated into
that salad
but isn't it the same thing with soup no
why
because it's because it's it's reduced
and changed into something else with
soup
and i can't remember the last time i
just soup with a with steak in it
i mean i guess beef stew maybe i mean
but for christ's sake sal
when you go to the store to buy meat for
soup it's the shittiest
cuts of the meat it's horrible they got
these chunks
that they have to label
unless it sits in liquid for nine hours
i refuse
to attach that argument to my argument
for soup
i didn't tell you that my soup's gonna
contain the lowest quality ingredients
it does
no no no it doesn't it doesn't you
nobody makes do uh beef stew with filet
mignon you make it with stew meat that's
what stew meat's for yeah but
i but you're telling me that inedible
food is going into a soup what i'm
saying sorry don't try to
i'm saying it has to be transformed to
become edible
and that's what happens in soup with
salad you can take a quality steak and
put it right on top of the lettuce and
just eat it like that
there is no it's got a beautiful ginger
ginger based soup
oh my god it's unbelievable a ginger
it's just a light bro i make a part of
it i eat it all
sunday all right by the way ah we can
okay first okay ready can you can you
give me um can you blow up that screen
yeah all right so we do not know yeah
let me see
how many votes have been cast thus far
10 000 almost 10
500 excellent definitely soup i love a
salad but a nice hot bowl of homemade
soup
is a lot more appealing than a bowl of
leaves
can't remember the last time i said i
could really go for a salad
okay all right soup isn't a meal
it's a waste of space in my stomach
soup takes up valuable space lettuce
doesn't do that
soup is savory it fills you with warmth
and there are so many different kinds
broccoli cheddar is superior didn't even
name that one i appreciate a good salad
at a restaurant but only at a restaurant
they're never good at home soup all the
way you listen to this person what
they're saying
salad is never good at home what did
what what i don't disagree i know what
they mean
when i make a salad it's never as good
as a restaurant salad stop it
stop it this guy's saying minestrone
bring it on soup
you can do so many different things with
soup it's very versatile
okay
[Laughter]
no no that's not that's fake all right
well come on
are you 100 to zero joe pull you i do
love you
i pull that head of lettuce out of your
ass i do i do love both
i do love both but i love a good chicken
caesar salad and eat salads more than
soup
there you go soup hands down do you know
how many different kinds of soup you can
make
savory sweet hot cold if you picked
salad you probably have a ten plus year
old goldfish
wrapped in tin foil in your freezer at
your mom's place that's crazy names
though
that's contradicting your argument
you're the one that said you could take
anything out of the fridge and turn it
into a
stew salad you could put whatever you
want and anyone that says soup is 75
years old or a serial killer all right
no way
that's up for number one that's up for a
winning comment
i cannot deal with people who like soup
it is something i'm so against when
you're washing dishes
and accidentally touch the wet food and
the drain it probably that's not a
reason to not pick soup if this is a
dinner party
salad the sound of people eating soup
makes me want to die
salad is the winner i beg to differ
lettuce in the winter tastes different
than when it's in season
if you baste the dish if it's not
consistent what's the point
all right let's see who there are
seasonal biases soup is more comforting
salad sucks all right we got a nice mix
so this is gonna be close i think it's
been close
let's see you want pimp reveal this baby
humble pie
10 702 votes in the last half hour
57.8 goes to your boy
soup yeah baby
all right yeah another thing i didn't
realize too is like we started tallying
the records
but they were like out of like we didn't
play everything
so right now in essence this is really
the 13th episode we've ever recorded uh
but i do want to no so right now in
essence uh
eight episodes have aired right i wonder
what our record is
yeah i don't know yeah i don't know but
i'd like to know though because i
i think that like you somehow or another
like
put a bunch of w's in a row with me i
did last time we recorded i
won all four that helped me greatly take
it take it down a notch
all right folks that's our show oh oh
the winning tweet it's gotta be the the
guy that said soup makes me sick or what
it was funny that was the funniest one
where's he at
now yeah yeah the serial killer one
that's great
salad salad you can put whatever you
want in it anyone who says soup is 75
years old her serial killer
our winner is at alwayswinning48
at alwayswinning48 that's our show
people
thanks for listening to us i still love
you
so love you jonah rosa comedy on
instagram and twitter
at savvolcano across the socials you
found us here on the no press
network we also have the hay bay podcast
uh
joey rose's sandwich shop at the stand
you want to give those hours and
whatnots
we gave them in the ad okay all right uh
yeah thanks guys
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs